flu and welcome to see you playing
colstrip on Denmark okay Kings Indian
the same ish okay maybe I can do
something oh that's that's rare it's
real way of playing this opening oh ok
maybe six and A five maybe this is this
kind of setup often quite quite good
let's see okay just he loses a temple
here I can go if five and put this on
deform there are there's a line um it's
quite quite similar in nature but he
currently has this line with about to
tempe down and the capture hmm I don't
know it's that really good I'm really
happy about this my position looks good
be this one mm-hmm I can also just go
see five of course fantastic night right
see 596 also looks tempting
I don't know too many too many good
options
yeah i still can go see five I think
I'll do that and now f5 or not I think I
do this I can go if or at the end by
text x f4 key for I have everything on
the D foursquare so it should be
possible to keep that oh I think I told
them but gives me more development it
looks it looks a little bit like well at
it out well it cannot be a specially
cough but it has some sveshnikov motives
so what's the deal if i go here is gone
either for Gaston that's player wants to
go to d3 huh ok but I've Queen a5 here
it isn't this a pin and now let's grab
it so what's going on here um Mike Mike
Wheaton doesn't have many squares ok
don't tell me it's strapped to ok one
that would be really crazy that would be
crazy yeah but might be right how do i
how do i evacuate the Queen rook be
three or something
that's crazy
who be three okay one yeah probably have
to thats it's really really funny when
he didn't sequin 85 I mean he blundered
into crenate five and then a three Queen
takes and help of a queen is trapped
it's really crazy in case you want to
post I don't give enough credit to my
opponents and so on you know nobody
plays night before allowing Queen a five
to play a 3 this is just not happening
so anyway the situation is also
completely unclear i think if he goes
look a one-out tikka t3 yeah we'll see
what happens yeah so i have to give this
unfortunately and now I'm yet to a five
I guess
no so takes this one
hmm yeah I don't have a clear
continuation here yeah now maybe I
should take I mean pinning is not so
great because of d5 and when you can
take twice I thought d5 is good maybe
i'm wrong but it looked okay to me
Wow
now he's playing miracles I love that
check
can you six strong unfortunately time
warner is strong now i can go here
Bishop takes you should see eight you
know please Quincy eight for a draw or
what yes yeah 46 seconds I'll try to
offer draw him now he plays on time
fantastic and then blundering e5 and
cool
let's do it wrong but
and now I've done during each for one of
those games where you just really don't
know what to say I can so he plays this
and stumbles into a queen here and now I
probably shouldn't take I mean this is
the thing I just took their
automatically and didn't didn't really
think much about it if I don't take I'm
just better I guess he's still in the
pin this is given as the this is the
computers more with back being clearly
bad black bean clearly better I mean I
have the scent i have the two bishops
and so on it's pretty clear that legs
better I just didn't see that 93 trap
set and now we have this this absolutely
weird position mm-hmm should take on c4
now I group t6 but he did that and now
yeah I have to avoid route g5 huh this
one name you this is a strong move this
is what the computer is giving it's
entirely unrealistic there see that but
it's it's an interesting move and he had
rook t5 jack yeah we are just about
holding okay Bishop f5 is the draw and
this is not the way for white to try to
play to win I think why should probably
be able to do that to win somehow
between the seven or so yeah this is
this is just the drawn ending okay there
was some adventures of adventures
afterwards but if they decline to draw
in a position like that I simply don't
take the game series any more happy to
be honest um yeah I should have not
taken only three is ok thanks for
watching